خرج الالاف في احتجاجات جديده بتل ابيب ضد
خطه حكومه نتنياهو لتغيير نظام القضائي
مطالبين بالغائه وليس فقط تاجيله وذكر
بيان للحركه الاحتجاجيه ان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه فشلت في كل المجالات وتعتزم
تمرير مع اعتبروهم انقلابا قضائيا خلال
عطله الكنيست بدلا من التركيز على الامن
من جهه اخرى قال شقيق المتهم بتنفيذ عمليه
تل ابيب امس انما حدث مع شقيقه مجرد حادث
سير نتج عن الارهاق مرجعا سبب وفاه السائح
الايطالي الى رصاص الشرطه الاسرائيليه
المنطقه التي كان فيها كل نعرفها كل اضواء
ودائما تغييرات فيمكن ان تبدل ومثبت هذا
الشيء انه بسرعه حاول ان يبعد عن مسار
ودخل
في داخل نجيل وقلبت السياره لو كان عنده
نيه لهذا الشيء لاكمل الامر
وفعل ما فعل وهذا بتقرير
ماذا ونحن نؤمن ونطق في مكان جديد لانهم
حياديين في كل هذه الامور ويعملون بثقه
وبامانه وهذا شيء معروف لا نكران فيه
يقولون ان السائح قتل جراء الرصاص
الشرطي او من كان هناك يدعي ان يوسف حاول
حاول ان يمسك سلاح وتم تحييده اذا فلم يكن
هناك اطلاق سلاح نار من يوسف نهائيا فمن
لدى اطلق النار عليه وما يؤكد هذا الشيء
انهم اشتبهوا في هذا
السائح انه شاب في الثلاثينات وصورته تدل
من بعيد على ملامح عربيه وخصوصا ان نختار
رخبطه الامور على شرطي
قبل ذلك قرر وزيره الجيش الاسرائيلي ابقاء
الاغلاق المفروض على الفلسطينيين في ضفه
الغربيه مستمرا حتى مساء الخميس اضافه الى
استمرار اغلاق المعابر مع قطاع غزه حتى
نهايه مساء الاربعاء يشمل ذلك ايضا الغاء
الاجراء المدني المصادقه عليه لشهر رمضان
ومنع دخول العمال من غزه الى اسرائيل
معنى من القدس مراسله العربيه لنا قلغاسي
لنا اهلا بك معنا ابدا معك من جديد
الاحتجاجات في اسرائيل
ومطالبتهم بالغاء التعديلات القضائيه ما
جديد هذه الاحتجاجات وتعامل الشرطه
الاسرائيليه مع المحتاجين الاسرائيليين
صحيح فعليا نتحدث عن الاسبوع الرابع عشر
على التوالي خروج عشرات الالاف من
المتظاهرين الاسرائيليين للشوارع تل ابيب
حيفا ومناطق اخرى في اسرائيل ولكن هذه
المره كان هناك حذر اكبر من قبل الشرطه
الاسرائيليه حيث طالبوا المتظاهرين بعدم
اغلاق اي الشوارع بسبب الاوضاع الامنيه
وكان هناك ايضا مطالبه بعد تقييم الاوضاع
مساء اليوم كان هناك جلسه لتقييم الاوضاع
وطالبوا ايضا بنشر تعزيزات
للقوات الاسرائيليه الخاصه جنبا الى جنب
القوات القوات الشرطه المتواجده في تل
ابيب بسبب الاوضاع الامنيه الحرجه ولكن
هذه المره المتظاهرين يعني يخرجون لثلاثه
اسباب الاولى بسبب التعديلات القضائيه هم
يطالبون بالغائها بشكل كامل وليس فقط
تاجيلها اما السبب الثالث الثاني عفوا وهو
انشاء الحرس الوطني الذي طالب به بن جفير
والحكومه صادقت ووافقت على انشائه صحيح
سوف تكون هذه الوحده تحت سيطره تحت سيطره
وزير الامن القومي اعتمر بن جفير ما يقوله
الاسرائيليين هذه ديكتاتوريه وهو اعطاء
جيش كامل لاحد المتطرفين وسوف يقوم
باستغلاله بشكل عنصري وخاطئ اما السبب
الثالث وهو الفشل الامني لهذه الحكومه
بسبب الاوضاع الامنيه المتوتره والمتوتره
جدا
الاخير الذي يخرج بسببه المتظاهرون في
اسرائيل كنا نتابع مشهدا مباشرا اذا لهذه
الاعداد الكبيره من المحتجين اذا كما
ذكرتي التي خرجت اليوم في عده مناطق
احتجاجا على الاصلاحات القضائيه
وانشاء الحرس الوطني واقتطاع ميزانيته من
وزارات اخرى كذلك والفشل الامني عند هذا
السبب الاخير لنا طبعا الاراضي الفلسطينيه
تشهد توترا كبيرا في اليومين الماضيين
التوتر الامني والتصعيد الحاصل
لم يؤثر على ما يبدو على هذه الحركه
الاحتجاجيه داخل اسرائيل
صحيح ما زال المتظاهرين يعني مصرين انهم
يخرجوا الى الشارع بغض النظر عن الاوضاع
الامنيه المتوتره وصعبه جدا ولكن هناك
ايضا دعوات من قبل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
تقول دعنا فعليا نركز على امن اسرائيل
لنقوم بتاجيل هذه المظاهرات ولكن على ما
يبدو ان الشعب الاسرائيلي مصر لانه يعني
يتعامل مع حكومه عنصريه حسب ما يصفوها طيب
لنا بعيدا عن الاحتجاجات دعيني اسالك عن
ما وقع بالامس في المنتزه على شاطئ تل
ابيب ما قيل انها عمليه عمليه مزدوجه
عمليه دهس واطلاق نار شقيق منفذ العمليه
يقول انه لا يعني هو لم يقصد
ان يكون هناك عمليه بل هو حادث سير هل
تكشفت المزيد من التفاصيل حول ما وقع على
شاطئ تل ابيب بالامس
الشرطه الاسرائيليه بطبيعه الحال عند وقوع
مثل هذه العمليات لا تقوم بنشر فيديوهات
اذا كان الجانب الفلسطيني على حق لذلك
شقيق الشاب الذي اتهم بتنفيذ هذه العمليه
طالب الشرطه الاسرائيليه بتوفيق الروايه
الاسرائيليه وقال ان ضابط الشرطه هو الذي
اطلق النار على شقيقه وبطبيعه الحال
الضابط هو يعني يحمل الكاميرا على صدره
ويعني عند حدوث اي حدث مطلوب من هذا
الضابط تشغيل الكاميرا لتوثيق ما يتم
حدوثه لذلك الشقيق الشاب اكد بانه شاب
مسالم هو ايضا يتعامل بشكل يومي مع اعداد
كبيره من اليهود وهو يعني لديه ايضا محل
تجاريه وهناك اعداد كبيره منهم
يذهبون الى المحل التجاريه ويقول انا لديه
اشقاء ولا لديه عائله ولا يوجد لديه اي
نيه من تنفيذ هذه العمليه هو فقط في
الايام الاربعه الاخيره بلا نوم بسبب حاله
وفاه من احد اقاربه لذلك ربما يعني هذا
فعليا حادث السير وهي امور طبيعيه تحدث
ولكن الشرطه الاسرائيليه تتهم هذا الشاب
حيازته الى السلاح ولكن حتى الان لا يوجد
اي توفيق للروايه الاسرائيليه تثبت حيازه
هذا الشاب على سلاح حقيقي شكرا لك لنا كل
غاصي كنت معنا مباشره من القدس لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات